Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Nicoletta Pedrana
Mi presento, sono Marta S a c h y - Sachy.
Sono donna, antropologa,
cooperante internazionale,
mamma, figlia e molto altro.
Ma soprattutto, sono nera.
Per quelli che dicono
che gli italiani neri non esistono,
potete dire che avete assistito
ad un TEDTalk con un ologramma,
nell'epoca del metaverso.
Essere qui, per me oggi -
(Applausi)
è un onore, ma soprattutto un dovere
per riflettere insieme su concetti quali:
pluralità culturale;
privilegio bianco; antirazzismo.
Come molti di voi, sono nata
su questo fantastico lago -
ma non come voi.
Nel senso: tutti abbiamo storie diverse,
ma ovviamente la mia è stata
contrassegnata dalla mia nerezza.
Agli inizi degli anni '80,
sono stata una delle prime bambine
nate da una coppia mista.
Mio papà bianco, comasco
di origini francesi -
che spiega la stranezza del mio cognome -
e mia mamma mozambicana, nera
ma con discendenze portoghesi e indiane.
Sono stata la prima bambina
ad essere battezzata nella mia parrocchia.
La prima nella mia squadra di pallavolo.
La prima a frequentare
il liceo classico di Lecco.
La prima ad iscriversi
a Sociologia in Bicocca.
Ho da sempre vissuto
la solitudine del mio corpo nero.
Infatti, io e mio fratello
eravamo gli unici neri
in un paesino di 3.300 abitanti sul lago.
Quando ero piccola,
non mi rendevo conto di essere diversa;
ma poi, crescendo,
dovevo sempre più spesso
rispondere a domande del tipo:
"Wow! Ma perché parli
così bene l'italiano?",
"Ma ti senti più italiana o più africana?"
Mi veniva voglia di dire:
"Sai, dipende dalle stagioni".
(Risate)
"Ma posso dire che sei
la mia amica nera, o è un insulto?"
Beh, dipende come lo usi.
Mi ricorderò sempre quando la mamma
di una mia amica mi ha detto:
"All'inizio ero molto preoccupata
che mia figlia ti frequentasse;
ma poi, ho scoperto che sei una come noi."
Mi chiedo ancora oggi
se sia stato un complimento.
Avevo 14 anni quando mi sono resa conto
che il colore della mia pelle
mi avrebbe per sempre contrassegnata.
Stavo aspettando un'amica
per andare agli allenamenti di pallavolo,
quando un uomo si è avvicinato
e mi ha offerto dei soldi
al ciglio della strada:
ed ero incappucciata e con la tuta.
Oltre a questi episodi,
immaginate che cosa possa significare
vivere in un ambiente
dove il corpo nero è considerato
come sporco, pericoloso, sessualizzato.
E non hai immagini
con le quali rispecchiarti:
niente sui libri di favole;
sul sussidiario;
al bancone del bar; in banca; in tv.
E devo dire che questa mancanza
di rappresentatività
disorienta molto,
quando stai costruendo
e accettando la tua identità.
Specialmente quando, intorno a te,
l'identità viene venduta
come sinonimo di omologazione
ad un modello monocromatico,
monolinguistico, monoculturale.
Un modello che sottrae, mentre la mia
è un'identità elevata al cubo.
In Italia, portare in giro
la mia nerezza era sfiancante.
Toni Morrison dice
che la funzione principale del razzismo
è quella di distrarti,
di impedirti di fare il tuo lavoro;
e di costringerti, sempre,
a giustificare la legittimità
ad occupare un qualsiasi posto,
specialmente se questo posto è di potere.
E considerate che io sono
fra i neri privilegiati:
nata con la cittadinanza italiana;
mai dovuto saltare
gite scolastiche all'estero;
mai fatto lunghe code in questura
per rinnovare il permesso di soggiorno.
E ammettiamolo:
quando le forze dell'ordine ti fermano,
e vedono che sei italiana,
be', lasciano passare.
In Italia, la mia identità al cubo
era incompatibile
con l'ambiente in cui vivevo.
Avevo una scelta: annullarmi o andarmene.
E ho deciso, e potuto, andarmene.
Sono approdata in Inghilterra.
Lì mi sono sentita invisibile,
ma non invisibilizzata.
Il colore della mia pelle era accettato
anche quando dicevo che ero italiana.
Ho studiato antropologia sociale
e cooperazione internazionale.
Col senno di poi, credo,
una sorta di psicanalisi accademica
per capire chi fossi
e perché ricevevo i giudizi
degli altri di un certo tipo.
Ho studiato che l'Africa
è un continente di cui andare fieri,
per la sua storia e per le sue culture,
specialmente precoloniali.
Ho studiato che non esistono schiavi,
ma persone che sono state schiavizzate;
e che la storia è, ovviamente,
stata scritta dai vincitori.
Perché se chi l'ha persa l'avesse scritta,
beh, ci vergogneremmo
di quello che è successo
e di quello che sta succedendo nel mondo.
Ho anche studiato
che le relazioni secolari
di potere, e razziali,
continuano ad influenzare l'accessibilità
alle opportunità sociali ed economiche
a cui tutti dovremmo avere diritto.
E ho anche appreso, sui libri,
che il razzismo non si limita
ad episodi personali,
ma è una pratica sociale
strutturale a mantenere
lo status quo di ingiustizie globali
a favore delle classi dominanti.
Personalmente, ho fatto pace
con la mia identità;
e mi sono resa conto
che quando le costrizioni discriminatorie
determinano la tua esistenza,
beh, ha senso accoglierle.
E renderle strumento
per lottare contro quella parte
di società che ti è ostile,
e cercare di migliorare la società tutta.
Dal 2007, lavoro
in cooperazione internazionale.
Sin da piccola mi sono resa conto
che l'unica differenza fra me
e i miei cugini mozambicani
era la pura e semplice casualità.
Io, nata nei fantastici anni '80
nel Nord Italia;
e loro in Mozambico,
durante la guerra civile.
In Brasile e in Mozambico,
ho toccato con mano
la vuota retorica dietro la frase
"Volere è potere":
perché, ovviamente,
il posto dove nasci e dove cresci
ha un'incidenza su quello che puoi fare,
e quello che puoi diventare.
Ho cominciato a lavorare
a Salvador de Bahia,
la città più nera fuori dall'Africa;
e lì mi sono resa conto quotidianamente
di che cosa significa essere diseguali,
perché camminando nella stessa strada
puoi avere a destra il quartiere più ricco
e a sinistra il quartiere più povero
della stessa città.
Ho appreso come dinamiche
di segregazione e di marginalizzazione
continuano ad ostacolare
una genuina mobilità sociale,
e per la prima volta ho sentito nominare
le parole "razzismo istituzionale".
Poi, in un impeto
"Going back to the roots",
sono andata in Mozambico,
dove ho voluto lavorare
in un distretto rurale,
a ore dalla prima città,
per capire come vivessero
le persone in quell'ambiente,
soprattutto in un Paese
in via di sviluppo.
Lì mi sono resa conto
della straordinarietà delle persone,
che vivono e lavorano molto di più
dei miei noti concittadini brianzoli,
ma non arrivano neanche a quello
che noi definiremmo
le condizioni minime di vita.
Ho anche scoperto
come le narrazioni
infantilistiche verso l'Africa
continuino a ritardarne lo sviluppo.
Sono una professionista ottimista,
idealista, molto concreta;
ma alle volte, anche molto frustrata.
Probabilmente per la mia storia personale,
ho deciso di dedicare la mia vita
a compensare quelle che sono
le diseguaglianze globali.
Lo faccio avendo consapevolezza
del posto di privilegio da cui parlo;
e soprattutto, mettendomi sempre
nei panni degli altri,
anche quando questi sono scomodi
e poco immediati.
Esercizi che consiglio
di fare a tutti voi.
Poi, l'amore -
tra l'altro, per un lecchese -
mi ha riportata in Italia.
Ho cominciato a lavorare a Roma
dove, sebbene ero vestita in tailleur,
c'erano delle difficoltà a capire
che cosa ci facessi seduta
a tavole di riunioni importanti.
Molte volte sentivo dire
"Ué te, fa figo avere una nera nel team!".
Come se fosse, non lo so,
una pennellata di colore,
un'elemosina, un gettone.
Da quattro anni, però,
dirigo una fondazione
dove abbiamo deciso di focalizzarci
su quello che funziona in Africa,
i tanti aspetti positivi
di cui poco si sente parlare.
Tra i quali: i giovani, l'innovazione,
la volontà di riscatto.
Ci occupiamo di collaborare e supportare
giovani imprenditori africani
che hanno iniziative ad impatto sociale
nelle loro comunità.
Lo facciamo ascoltando,
rispondendo alle loro
richieste specifiche,
dando assistenza tecnica quando richiesto;
e soprattutto, cercando di cambiare
la narrazione verso l'Africa.
Infatti, questo è uno dei nostri
principali obiettivi:
decolonizzare gli stereotipi
sul continente africano.
Un esempio concreto
di quello che facciamo?
L'anno scorso, abbiamo portato cinque
di questi fantastici imprenditori africani
alla Borsa Valori di Milano:
un posto tradizionalmente
non accessibile -
e anche molto bianco -
per presentare i propri business.
Quando mi hanno chiesto
di partecipare a questo TEDx,
e parlare del mio essere
diversamente italiana,
sinceramente ho sentito
un grande senso di disagio.
Infatti, parlare di nerezza e razzismo
molte volte provoca la reazione del tipo:
"Ma dai, Marta, che palle!
Ma non esagerare, ma guardati!
Ma il razzismo non esiste!"
Sono qui perché credo fermamente
che le discriminazioni siano ingiuste,
e non debbano essere perpetuate
neanche per scherzo.
Inoltre, da tre anni sono mamma
di un bimbo, bianco,
a cui cambio la ninnananna
quando arriva la strofa
"Lo darò all'uomo nero
che lo tenga un anno intero",
(Risate)
perché sappiamo tutti che l'uomo nero
non è un personaggio di fantasia.
E non voglio che interiorizzi il razzismo
prima che impari le moltiplicazioni.
All'asilo mi scambiavano per la sua tata.
Vantaggio per non entrare a far parte
dei gruppi WhatsApp di classe
Al parco -
(Applausi)
Al parco, alcuni bambini mi chiedono
dove sia la sua mamma.
E ancora, non trovo libri
che parlino della nostra famiglia.
Il fatto che lui possa crescere,
e avere vergogna
delle sue origini africane,
e delle persone
più importanti della sua vita,
mi porta ancora una volta
a voler contribuire a destrutturare
quelle che sono le gabbie mentali
che alimentano il razzismo.
Io ho deciso di non essere schiava
di una sola storia,
ma di essere la somma di varie.
Mio marito mi prende in giro
dicendo che, a seconda
di come mi sveglio al mattino,
sono lecchese, romana, bahiana,
mozambicana, afroitaliana.
Spero che la mia storia
sia una riflessione sociopolitica
sulla complessità.
Io, come altri di seconde generazioni,
altri residenti stranieri qua in Italia,
sono un soggetto mediatore
tra passato e futuro,
tra tre continenti diversi,
tra gruppi sociali differenti.
Un soggetto transculturale, ibrido,
probabilmente non facilmente
decodificabile
ma che vuole, partendo
dalla sua esistenza,
cominciare ad aggregare valore
a questa società.
So benissimo che l'Italia sta cambiando:
ad oggi ci sono circa 1.500.000
di residenti di origine straniera;
tuttavia, l'idea di italianità
è ancora molto legata
all'idea di bianchezza.
E quando vado nelle scuole superiori,
in queste fantastiche
classi multiculturali,
e parlo della mia esperienza,
alla fine del mio intervento
alcuni alunni arrivano da me,
e dicono: "Ma sai che anche a me
succedono le stesse cose?
E anch'io voglio aggregare valore
alla mia società."
Io credo fermamente
che la diversità sia l'unicità,
ovvero quel potenziale individuale
che va oltre classificazioni
e preconcetti.
La mia famiglia afroeuropea
continua ad essere arricchita
da questa unicità.
Ora ho una cognata australiana,
di origini ebree;
e ho una nipotina stupenda, speciale,
con un cromosoma in più.
Spero che anche voi possiate andare
oltre le banalizzazioni stereotipate,
e le ipersemplificazioni che dividono,
e possiate aprirvi alla complessità.
E aprendovi alla complessità,
scoprirete che le alborelle fritte
con il curry mozambicano
sono deliziose.
(Applausi)